bella tutti ragazze venute questo video
sono famiglie e oggi siamo scesi in
between che vuol dire lei e in mezzo in
mezzo dove in mezzo alle prime crepe a
non è un insulto a c'è un ok
salve sembra la grafica dei doni nella
morte quando ti spiegano che la morte
prende la gente già ho detto morte ho
detto che l'epa l'inizio del d la
monetizzazione giocata sono le gesta di
goku non so ragazzi non capisco si
stavano passando questa palla va bene o
capo una è una cinese l'altra crudelia
de mon
non si capisce dove mio figlio non
l'altra one crudelia demon l'altra il
demonio proprio damon vero bene allora
io non so a chi si parte così va bene io
è un gioco e una demo per non lo so se
non avremo nessun gioco pieno però
abbiamo una lanterna che è fantastico si
parte permesso
sono quello che che muore questo è un
armadio bene ecco io in giappone sono
sempre avuto problemi perchè quando apro
le porte non so mai se un armadio o se è
un'altra stanza però vabbè c'è un
pallottoliere bene ragazzi non ho mai
visto una casa così tetra nella mia vita
il problema non è tanto che c'è gente
indesiderata in questa calda è però non
è che mi ci sono svegliato dentro e non
so neanche cosa devo fare
mi devo nascondere negli armadi o che è
questa cosa mi sta piacendo o cosa che
ho trovato un totem eno cielo anche qui
permesso non capisco dove devo andare
cosa devo fare noi anche dove stasto
mezzo dove si trova a lei doveste mezzo
a puoi uscire che figo sento dei rumori
tetri provenire da destra il che mi
porta ad andare a sinistra quindi
andiamo a sinistra ma io cosa devo è
tipo slider mansion e se devo trovare
tutti i pezzi prima che sta qua mia
guanti le chiappe sento rumori
ho sentito rumori là in fondo non
andiamo in fondo posso trovare altre
cose piazza l'amuleto
[Musica]
hanno messo proprio regalo è non ho
capito però cosa sai quindi ne devo
trovare altri o metterli molto bene
molto chiaro l'obiettivo di questo gioco
questo che mi hanno spiegato proprio
bene e sento dei respiri di ben a gol
verso la fine del corridoio non ho ben
capito che me li fa chi se ne frega
andiamo avanti
questa è l'altra muletto da voi ho
mescolato siamo calmi siamo tutti calmi
stiamo tutti calmi questo si apre bene
bene bene bene chiude benissimo mi sto
apre ecco sono dentro non mi poi pensano
nell'armadietto mi ha detto non puoi ma
c'è un determinato momento della mia
vita in cui tu sparisci dalla stanza
rimaniamo qua nell'armadietto tutto il
tempo uguale al mio braccio veramente
poco tentacolo zoe come si muove da
signori abbiamo un problema
la tizia equa destra la ci sono dei riti
satanici
cosa facciamo max che ciapet proprio
she's between the porta end e corridoio
cheese between proprio complimenti palo
non è l'unica porta per uscire quindi
posso appropinqua armi verso l'altra
porta e lei se ne sta la tranquilla
between secondo me l'ho pagata
speriamo ed io credo che spa universo
nelle altre stanze poi piovano lo so
comunque amuleti eccolo trovato trovato
trovo io sono fortissimo il suo gioco
mica perché l'ho firmata a between dei
corridoi proprio sul forte io
minchia che è pronto a cosa vado ma non
me l'aspettavo mai bene queste ronde
basta che da un po che non prendono già
perché così poi perché non si è sentito
il mittente
vabbè dovremmo essere morti teoria però
vabbè proviamo ad entrare nel gioco
dinho se riesco a scappare dubito devo
entrare i due entrati deve entrare
nell'armadietto niente c'è ne sono
stanco stanco nomi prendere sono stanco
sono una persona stanca fatti tagliare i
capelli da uno bravo per cortesia mi
stavo stato bravissimo
non ci credo mi sono salvato come è
possibile perché sarà dentro non puoi
scelte
no no no la porta chiusa la porta di
sporco demonio porco un armadietto per
cortesia non ragazzi cioè sta roba è
veramente corro minuto ma neanche con un
secondo ho messo l'altro amuleto puoi
stare ferma nella tua vita dati fatti
anche un bagno quando ti capita di
ritrovare armadietto ho trovato quattro
amuleti impossibile cioè come primo
tentativo
io ci metto la firma cioè non so se n'è
andata posso uscire o me la ritrovo in
bocca tipo si prova ragazzi c'è un
problema cioè mi segue veramente
tantissimo non c'è un momento in cui
sparisce mi segue veramente un sacco e
io c'è una resistenza che fa veramente
pietà lei non le fa neanche le scale
alza la testa ci arrivano fatto che non
la sento arrivare quindi come mi giro
potrei trovarmi la in faccia da un
secondo all'altro
sto solo controllando non ci siano
intraprendere qualche poi non ci
vorrebbe tornare vabbè
scendiamo scendiamo visto che sono tutti
molto ospitali qua
roberta non so bene chi sia però via
mi fa piacere che c'è gente che mi segue
sacco di follo verso ultimamente
fratello non è vero che società non mi
ami ami ha immobilizzato bene via via
via via via veloce veloce che ho trovato
c'è un'altra zia che è diversa e più
piccola penso sia la figlia non so ma
qua c'è questa roba demoniaca sul muro
forse si sblocca più avanti non so
comunque vorrei trovare altre muletti
grazie 8.000 piani perfetti passiamo
alta prevediamo un ascensore lì a porta
che sono cos'è sta roba qua vendono
tappeti cos'è un kimono enorme non
capisco ma io sono un bambino riuscita a
finalmene bel tempo almeno quello
sembrava casa quella di la città
incantata sembra un sacco quella
versione molto horror
vorrei trovare un altro amuleto se non
lo trovo state compare qualcuno posso
sempre suicidarmi quindi è un bene
ottimo gusto per i lampadari tra l'altro
lo è con amleto ci ho messo un anno e
mezzo per trovarne un altro perfetto ma
qualche grosso sto posto c'è il piano di
sopra enorme dovrei riuscire a ritrovare
la stanza gigante che dovrebbe essere
eccola qua fritschi one led
li ho messi tutti cioè penso a quante ne
vuoi ancora uva bene che natale
comprateli su amazon
so già che se vado avanti finisce male
quindi non so se è l'ultimo non lo so
sarebbe molto gradito se fosse l'ultimo
roberta non è roberta per lei muoverti
muoviti veloce che culo mi sono salvato
per niente mamma mia come ho fatto a
salvarmi
che culo vai vai vai veloce veloce per
lavare abort mission chissenefrega di
trovarne altre via via via via ho
rischiato non sono fatta non morire ho
rischiato tantissimo perché ti
immobilizzavano di vede una roba
orribile questo dimmi che l'ultimo
perché non so proprio domandavo era
l'ultimo
ho vinto fernanda è tornata in norvegia
perché originale la norvegia ve lo dico
io good job a chi you the feet per o
prima volta nella storia che il gioco ha
un qualcosa e lo finisco al precipuo
tentativo mai successo ma tutti phinet
freddy's renderman tutelero vedove di
ricercare le gli oggetti e portarli in
un posto mai successo che ho vinto al
primo tentativo mai e se ciò che
incredibilmente un casino non so se devo
ringraziare il clero che cosa ma sono
riuscito a b impossibile impossibile
quindi si swing però vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi sono orgoglioso di me perché se
ogni tanto faccio cose positive 5
milioni meritata per i ragazzi sono
video vi sia piaciuto momento mi piace
io sono contentissimo di aver vinto per
una volta non faccio una figura di cacca
serve se non ci si chiede è se siete fan
di fernanda mettete mi piace io lo so
beh ragazzi
[Musica]
no